l'invité politique d'i télé et ce soir
marielle de sarnez bonsoir marion sarnez
eurodéputés la vice présidente du modem
bras droit de françois bayrou on va
parler des élections à londres le
travailliste sadik khan est en poche est
en passe de remporter la mairie face aux
conservateurs zac goldsmith si vous
étiez londonienne vous auriez voter pour
qui pour lui ça dit que oui absolument
pour une raison extrêmement simple il
est extrêmement européen eelv il a dit
je serais si je suis élu maire de
londres le meneur de la campagne contre
le bike site
eh ben ça ça me fait très plaisir ça
fait plaisir qu'une personnalité
politique qui va peut-être on va voir
dans les heures qui viennent de venir le
maire de londres rappelle que oui
l'europe c'est bien et qu'il faut y
rester et qui croient dans cet idéal
européen
il est issu d'une famille pauvre
musulmane en l'occurrence on a beaucoup
rappelé pendant la campagne ce serait
possible en france une telle succès
story oui on l'a beaucoup rappelé un
familles musulmanes et jeu il ya quelque
chose je pense qu'on doit pas qualifié
par sa religion je vous dis comme je le
pense j'ai regardé sur google son nom de
j'ai vu toute son histoire
il a une superbe histoire d'abord il est
européen je viens de le dire c'est un
fils d'émigrés pakistanais sont peintes
et conducteurs de bus et donc il a fait
toute une campagne aussi au fond pour
que les londoniens les plus modestes
d'entre eux parce qu'il vient d'une
famille modeste que ça aille mieux pour
eux demain dans les transports dans le
logement je trouve que c'est intéressant
dans un pays qui est très on va dire
ultralibéral quelquefois en économie
comme la grande bretagne et de ce point
de vue là je trouve qu'il a un profil
intéressant attachant mais moi le
qualifié par sa religion c'est quelque
chose que je me refuse à faire
inversement qu'est ce que vous reprochez
riez à zac goldsmith bas passé européen
j'ai dit hier c'est exactement
exactement cela on voit bien que les
conservateurs sont gênés aux entournures
par cette affaire européenne
tout ça parce que cameron à l'intérieur
de son parti d'abord boris johnson le
maire de londres sortant qui fait la
campagne pour le politique donc l'europe
s'est invitée dans cette campagne
si les londoniens choisi sa mère
européen ça sera un signal positif
je trouve y voit l'avion dont les
résultats vous fait le parallèle avec la
campagne pour le référendum à majdi
ça a un sens peut-être peut-être quel
est l'intérêt des britanniques selon
voies à rester dans l'union justement
c'est l'intérêt des britanniques c'est
de rester dans l'union parce que
évidemment que seuls avec les défis qui
sont ceux du monde d'aujourd'hui on a vu
tout à l'heure on a parlé de la syrie on
n'a pas à être palmyre on a parlé des
bombardements sur le camp de réfugiés je
pourrais continuer la liste des défis
qu'ils sont mais extrêmement lourd
extrêmement important qui se rajoute aux
défis économiques qu'on connaît tous
aujourd'hui en europe
évidemment que l'union fait la force
c'est quelque chose de simple mais qui
convient vraiment de rappeler donc
j'aimerais qu'on se penche à présent sur
une phrase d'angela merkel prononcé cet
après midi en italie
la chancelière allemande a appelé ses
collègues européens à défendre les
frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne pour éviter un retour au
nationalisme les mais la raison est la
raison vous êtes à l'arrêt il faut
défendre les frontières extérieures
schengen va mourir si les européens sont
pas capables les chefs d'état
gouvernement de mettre en place qu'il
faut mettre en place aux frontières
extérieures vous aider quand il faut
réaliser schengen sur les risques qu'il
faut ré fut par lens vous êtes d'accord
également subi a dit rice en avant on
doit bien qu'il ya des risques
d'isolationnisme d'égoïsmes nationaux
qui prennent le pas sur le collectif on
le voit absolument tous les jours et
donc la responsabilité des chefs d'état
gouvernement angela merkel de ce point
de vue la raison
j'aimerais entendre françois hollande
sur cette question je ne l'entends pas
oui il faut avancer pour avoir des
frontières extérieures qu'ils soient
sécurisés où on contrôle les
ressortissants européens à leur antre à
leur sortie où on contrôle les
ressortissants des pays tiers où on
fasse comme les grands celui du monde a
confirmé on le décide
et si on le décide on peut le faire les
états unis durant dirigeants de mu les
états unis le font ils surveillent de
sang est streamé les etats unis les
volontés politiques d'accord sur leurs
façades par exemple maritime
ils ont des gardes frontières ils ont
des garde côtes mettons des
gardes-frontières mettons des garde
côtes
mettons des contrôles aux frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne a dit
aux frontières ils ont des frontières et
physique ses soutiens de schengen jeudi
des contrôles des contrôles me fait pas
lié à ce que j'ai pas du tout c'est pour
ça que je vous pose la dea nous tous je
ne suis pas de celles qu'il faut qu'ils
pensent qu'il faut reconstruire des murs
quand je vois des murs reconstruit
quelquefois
je pense que c'est de ce sont des échecs
appris comment vont-ils et contrôler les
frontières faux excentré blocage faisait
fiche peu juste finir il faut des
contrôles comble fait comme le font les
états unis d'amérique
par exemple et il faut aussi je parlais
des réfugiés il ya quelques minutes avec
ce qui s'est passé ce bombardement qui
n'est pas le premier d'ailleurs sur le
camp de réfugiés à la frontière turco
syrienne
il faut aussi qu'on ait un droit d'asile
respecter assumer et que ceux qui
veulent rejoindre l'union européenne par
exemple les syriens dont la vie est en
danger
puisse le faire par des voies légales
sans passer par des passeurs demain cela
fera quatre ans que françois hollande a
été élu à à l'elysée un mot pour
qualifier ces quatre ans d'abord ça
passe très vite mais ce que je vois
c'est que françois hollande dit que ça
va mieux moi je pense que c'est que les
français sont mais à l'opposé de ce
jugement la danse qui vivent tous les
jours mais plus grave encore c'est que
j'ai le sentiment que françois hollande
est reparti en campagne électorale c'est
à dire nous sommes à nouveau en campagne
pré électorale et donc ça veut dire
qu'on tape complètement un mandat et moi
ça m'inquiète pour mon pays
il ya encore du temps qui auraient pu
être utiles on est en campagne on fait
des cadeaux et des annonces à peu près
tous les jours mais nicolas sarkozy
avait fait la même chose la dernière
fois à la fin de son mandat celle n'y
avait pas porté chance je pense que ça
ne portera pas chance non plus à
françois hollande
alors françois bayrou lui et par
campagne soutient alain juppé c'est un
soutien inconditionnel
le modem est derrière juppé derrière je
ne sais pas en tous les cas moi ce que
je sais c'est que le pays a besoin
d'être rassemblée pour opérer un
redressement dont nous avons besoin les
français ils ont besoin de vivre mieux
demain pour vivre mieux
il va falloir je vous le dis vraiment
dépassé les affaires on va dire
partisane et pouvant nourrir des
rassemblements plus large et il faudra
aussi des changements des changements
importants dans la manière de gouverner
mais c'est vraiment un soutien sans
condition aujourd'hui alors que alain
juppé n'a pas encore présenté son
programme à tout le monde sait que alain
juppé a au moins cette volonté déjà de
rassembler je trouve que de ce point de
vue là c'est intelligent qui fera faire
croire qu'il va relever le défi de
toutes les difficultés auxquelles nous
avons à faire face que ce soit dans
notre école dans notre économie
dans la société française en étant
simplement avec des réflexes partisans
du lierre il va falloir dépasser tout ça
si c'est nicolas sarkozy qui remporte la
primaire à droite françois bayrou ira se
présentera en soit c'est alain juppé
remporte la primaire est donc
j'oeuvrerai dans ce sens là et si nous
préparer la landi et si nicolas sarkozy
est élu ce que moi je ne souhaite pas je
pense pas ce moment là on vous l'a dit
et redit vous seront libres vous serez
libre merci d'avoir été avec nous sur ce
plateau ce soit resté bien avec nous sur
i télé dans un instant la météo le
journal est évidemment le grand
décryptage sur l'élection à la mairie de
londres à tous les temps